who are the
144,000 the question of the 144,000 has
perplexed men and women down through the
centuries many students of the Bible
pastors and theologians have been
confused by that subject they've
attempted to answer it in different ways
some people believe that the 144,000 are
144,000 Jews that go out to preach the
gospel during the time of the
tribulation now you might be thinking
well isn't that true well we're going to
study
from scripture to find out what is true
let's throw off our preconceived ideas
let's cast off all man-made ideas and go
directly to the
Bible who are the
144,000 the question of the 144 th000
has perplexed men and women down through
the centuries many students of the Bible
pastors and theologians have been
confused by that subject they've
attempted to answer it in different ways
some people believe that the 144,000 are
144,000 Jews that go out to preach the
gospel during the time of the
tribulation now you might be thinking
well isn't that true well we're going to
study from scripture to find out what is
true let's throw off our preconceived
ideas is let's cast off all man-made
ideas and go directly to the Bible now
in the Bible the 144,000 are mentioned
in two places Revelation chapter 7 and
Revelation chapter 14 the seventh
chapter of the Book of Revelation is an
answer to a question that is raised in
Revelation chapter 6 in Revelation
chapter 6 the Bible is talking about the
Seven Seals and it interrupts those
seals with a question in Revelation 6:1
17 it says for the great day of his
wrath is come and who shall be able to
stand now you'd expect the answer to
that question who shall be able to stand
to be given in the next chapter and
you're right it is so Revelation chapter
7 that mentions the 144,000 is the
answer to the question who shall be able
to stand who will stand in the day when
Jesus Christ comes who will stand in the
day when the heavens are illuminated
with his glory who will stand in the day
when lightning flashes from the East and
to the west and Christ comes with 10,000
times 10,000 angels who will stand the
answer is given Revelation 7 verse
one after these things I saw four Angels
standing on the four corners of the
Earth holding the Four Winds of the
earth that that the wind should not blow
on the earth nor on the sea nor on any
tree now notice what you see in that
first verse because it's extremely
important the number four is mentioned
four times after these things I saw four
angels are there only four Angels not at
all there are 10,000 times 10,000 angels
it says on the four corners of the earth
I thought the Earth was round does it
have four corners not at all then it
says I saw the Four Winds of the earth
what's this talking about four four four
four in the Bible numbers take
significance the number seven is the
number of perfection for example you
have seven churches the perfect working
of God down through the centuries in
every CH one of his churches or as part
of his people then you have the Seven
Seals God's work down Through the Ages
as his church makes an impact on the
world you have the seven Trumpets the
seven perfect judgments of God and those
that have uh turned from his love and
spurned his grace and oppressed his
people so in the Bible numbers are
significant in the Bible you have the
number three in the Book of Revelation
you have the father Son and the Holy
Spirit it's a number of divinity but
then you also have the dragon the Beast
and the false prophet the false Divinity
that that Wars against the true Divinity
so the point is that numbers have
significance when the Bible speaks and
uses the number four it's using it to
illustrate the four points of the
compass north south east west it's kind
of
indicating totality totality is that
number so after these things I saw four
Angels well the Angels belt the Earth of
course but mentioning four is the total
Ministry of these angels as it circles
the Earth then it says Four Winds of the
earth and that the wind should not blow
on the earth nor on the sea it also
talks about the four corners of the
earth that's the four points of the
compass as we mentioned north south east
or west so these numbers are are
significant when it says the Four Winds
what is wind representing in the Bible
Well in Daniel chapter 7 a companion
book to the Book of Revelation we saw
wind uh blowing upon a turbulent sea as
beasts rise up out of the sea kingdoms
coming up amidst turmoil and conflict
Jeremiah chapter 49 is probably one of
the best chapters in the Bible to
understand the significance or the
meaning of winds Jeremiah the 49th
chapter and we're looking there at
Jeremiah 49 verse 36 and onward and
we're trying to discover what is the
meaning of the Winds and here in the
book of Jeremiah this is how it
describes it it says that the wind rose
and blue and and you look at Jeremiah
and and it describes the conflict and
the turmoil among nations and as it
describes that it points out here in
Jeremiah chapter 49 that the the
conflict that's taking place The Strife
that's taking place the struggle that is
taking place and it equates that
struggle with winds look at verse
3738 and onward for I will cause Elum to
be dismayed before their enemies and
before them that seek their life and I
will bring upon them my Fierce anger
sayth the Lord and I'll send the sword
after them and he says in verse 36 upon
eum will I bring the Four Winds from the
four quarters of Heaven I'll scatter
them toward those winds there'll be no
Nation so in verse 37 he says that his
anger is going to come upon them that
evil is going to come that war and
conflict and strife are going to come
and in verse 36 he says that's the winds
so in D in Revelation chapter 7 and
verse one
when we read about four winds blowing
upon the great sea there we read about
Four Winds on the four areas of the
compass what we're actually reading
about is strife and conflict coming upon
the world so with that understanding
let's go back and look at verse one of
Revelation 7 after these things I saw
four Angels that's God's angels belt the
Earth they hold back the Winds of strife
they hold back the destruction the
conflict they hold back the war and in
turmoil now sometimes we see little
gusts of that wind blow through the
fingers of those angels but all hell
will break loose in the last days of
verse history there'll be a time of
trouble according to the Bible such as
never has been in the history of the
world then it says I saw the angel
ascending from the East having the Seal
of the Living God and he cries with a
loud voice to the four angels to whom
was given to hurt the earth and the Sea
saying don't hurt the Earth the sea the
tree till we've sealed the Servants of
God in their foreheads now notice the
Seal of God is placed in the foreheads
so the great time of tribulation the
time of trouble will not come until the
Servants of God are sealed in the
foreheads now who is sealed what is the
Bible say about who sealed the Servants
of God so when the Bible describes
shortly the 144,000 it's describing the
Servants of God that are sealed in their
foreheads now what's this
sealing we know a lot about seals don't
we if you are married there is a seal on
your marriage certificate if you
graduate from high school or college
there's a seal on that degree if you for
example have a driver's license there'll
always be a little seal on that what is
a seal a seal is an official stamp that
authenticates a document so if you have
a legal document like a marriage license
the seal makes makes that document
authentic well does God have a legal
document with a seal in it Isaiah 8
verse 16 the Bible does tell us that God
has a legal document with a seal in it
here in Isaiah 8 verse 16 it
says bind up the testimony seal the law
among my disciples so God seal is in his
law verse 20 to the law and the
testimony if they speak not in according
to this words because there's no light
in them so to God's law to the testimony
of the prophets of scripture if they
don't speak according to his testimony
there is absolutely no light in them but
the seal is in God's law now who placed
the seal in God's law and who seals us
Ephesians chapter 4 now there are those
who have made a mistake in thinking that
the the holy spirit is the seal the holy
spirit is not the seal but the Holy
Spirit performs the sealing work
Ephesians chapter 4 and we're looking
there at verse 30 and grieve not the
holy spirit of God whereby you are
sealed unto the day of
redemption whereby you are sealed so the
holy spirit is the agency that writes
God's law on our hearts so that we are
settled in God God's truth so that
nothing can move us so in Revelation 7
when it introduces the answer to the
question who shall be able to stand it
is saying that there's a great time of
trouble coming There's a Great
Tribulation coming there's a great time
of difficulty coming but God will
seal through the ministry of the Holy
Spirit his law in the hearts and minds
of his people so that they will not be
moved when the Great crisis comes now a
SE
must contain at least three things it
must contain the name of the one that's
sealed that that's doing the cealing
must contain his title in his domain so
if you have a marriage certificate you
have a seal in it it'll tell you a
little bit about the person that's the
the justice of the peace or the
magistrat or the one who has the
authority to do the ceiling it'll tell
you what his domain is and it'll tell
you what his work is in his his title
His official title like for example you
might have Abraham Lincoln president
United States so you have the United
States as the seal you'll have the name
of the Seal of the president it'll have
his title as president and it will have
his domain United States so if there's a
seal in God's law what would that be
that would authenticate God's law where
do we find the seal in God's law do we
find it in the first commandment Thou
shalt have no other gods before thee we
could ask why who who says we shall have
no other gods do we find it in the
second commandment Thou shalt not bow
down to any Graven image who says do we
find it in the third commandment Thou
shalt not take the name of the Lord thy
God in vain what about the Commandment
that says Thou sh not kill or steal or
commit adultery or covet
Etc when you look through the entire law
there's only one Commandment that has
the qualifications for a seal that's the
fourth Commandment the Sabbath that says
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
sixth days shalt thou labor into all thy
work but the seventh day is the Sabbath
of the Lord thy God in it Thou shalt not
do any work thou thy son thy daughter
thy man sir thy maid sir thy cattle
within thy Gates why for in six days the
Lord made Heaven and Earth rested on the
seventh and the Lord Sanctified and
hallowed it look the Sabbath commandment
tells us that he is the Lord Our God
tells us he is the creator his title and
it tells us his domain Heaven and Earth
so the Sabbath is the Great Seal of
God's law it authenticates God's law
because it tells us that the one that
made us the one that created us the one
that fashioned and shaped us the one
that gave us life it tells us indeed
that he is our creator therefore he has
Authority so let's go back to Revelation
chapter 7 here in Revelation chapter 7
it says verse one verse two verse three
after these things I saw four Angels
standing on the four corners of the
Earth holding back the Four Winds so the
angels belt the Earth they totally
surround the Earth they hold back the
Four Winds of Destruction until
something happens until this Angel
descends from the East and he cries out
place a seal in other words lead God's
people through the Holy Spirit to have
the law of God written in their hearts
the law of God written in their minds
it's written in their hearts so they
love it written in their minds so they
know it and let the Seal of God the
Sabbath commandment be that command
that enables them to settle into the
truth in the last days of verse history
and let the Sabbath be the flag of their
allegiance let the Sabbath be the Seal
of their allegiance let the Sabbath be
the indication that they keep the entire
law namely through the blood of Jesus
Christ they are saved by faith now
through Grace they are saved by grace
through
faith we don't save ourselves by
obedience but Jesus says if you love me
do what keep my commands ments so God
will have an end time a commandment
keeping people now these people are
sealed and who are they according to
verse three they're the Servants of
God verse four I heard the number of
them that were sealed and there were
sealed 144,000 of all the tribes of the
children of Israel somebody says Pastor
Mark that confuses me because it says
that the ones that are sealed of all the
tribes of the children of Israel so you
have to ask who are Israelites in the
New Testament in the old Testament
Israel were God's people but let's see
if we can discover in the New Testament
who these Israelites are we're going to
look at some specific text Romans 2
verse 28 and 29 Romans 2 verse 28 and
29 for he is not a Jew which is one
outwardly neither is that circumcision
which is outward in the flesh but he is
a Jew which is one inwardly and
circumcision is not of the heart in the
spirit and not in the letter whose
praise is not a man but of God so here
Paul is saying in the Book of Romans
it's not being born a Jew it's not one
being outwardly a Jew but it's
circumcision of the heart in other words
when you accept Jesus Christ you become
one of Abraham's seed a spiritual
Israelite and HS according to the
promise when Israel as a corporate whole
and Nation turned its back on God
now it is true that thousands of Jews in
the outpouring of the Holy Spirit
accepted Christ but as a as a nation as
a corporate whole Jewish leadership
rejected Jesus and the Bible says in
Matthew the 23rd chapter your house is
left unto you desolate the veil in the
temple was split in two so now we're
looking not at literal Israel we're
looking at spiritual Israel the Church
of God look for example example at
Romans chap 9 verse
6-9 Romans 9: 6-9 who are Israelites in
the New Testament Romans 9 and we're
looking there at verse 6 not as though
the word of God haveth taken none effect
for they are not all Israel which are of
Israel they're not all Israel which what
does that mean it means not everybody
born a Jew is a spiritual Israelite
because they haven't accepted Christ
that's what Paul's point is here neither
because they are the Seed of Abraham are
they all children but in Isaac thy seed
shall be called so Romans 9 and Romans
10 talk about those who were not born as
natural Jews or Israelites being grafted
into the Olive Tree that is they are
becoming part of that larger family of
the children of Israel we find this also
very clearly mentioned in Galatians 3:29
9 Galatians 3: 29 it couldn't be clear
in the Bible in the New Testament we're
looking at
Galatians third chapter when the Book of
Revelation speaks about Israel it is
speaking about spiritual Israel
Galatians 3 verse 28 29 there is neither
Jew nor Greek there is neither Bond nor
free there is neither male nor female
nor for you are all one in Christ if you
are Christ you are what Abraham's seed
and hirs according to the promise so who
is it that are heirs according to the
promise that God gave Abraham the
promise of the promised land the promise
that one day we will live with Christ in
heaven Abraham was on his
way to a new country he went out
according to Hebrews 11 knowing a to a
country he didn't know where he was
going but he knew it was a better land
that God had prepared for him we are
Abraham's seed just as he was leading
ultimately the children of Israel to the
promised land he today is leading us to
the Heavenly promised land and as he
says so clearly in Galatians chapter
3 you are Abraham's seed if you've come
to Christ HS according to the promise so
who is a spiritual Israelite those that
have accepted Christ those for whom
Christ is all in all those who place
their sections on things above in as it
says in Colossians 3:2 those who seek
Christ first in all of his righteousness
as it says in Matthew
6:33 so let's go back to our passage now
and see what it says here in Revelation
CH 7 God is saying that a great time of
trouble is going to come upon the Earth
that before that time of Trouble Comes
God is going to send a message to the
whole world leading men and women back
to obedience to
him the holy spirit will lead them to a
deep conviction of the need for
obedience Saved By Faith Redeemed by
Grace they'll be led to obey God and
they will be led to keep his Sabbath the
Great Seal in the law of God and that
will be accomplished not through their
work but through the ministry of the
Holy Spirit now verse four I heard the
number of them which were sealed and
they were sealed 144,000 of all the
tribes of the children of Israel so who
are the tribes of the children of Israel
they are Spirit spiritual Israelites who
have accepted Jesus Christ This is a
term referring to the Church of God it's
a term referring to Believers it's a
term believing to the remnant of God who
are faithful at the coming of Jesus now
you say what about that number
144,000 is it a literal number of the
tribe of Judah were sealed 12,000 of the
tribe of Ruben 12,000 Gad 12,000 Asher
12,000 Nephilim 12,000 Manasses 12,000
Simeon 12,000 Levi 12,000 Isa 12,000
zabulon 12,000 Joseph 12,000 Benjamin
12,000 here's the problem if you say
this is a literal number that's
problematic because number one those 12
tribes don't exist today you can go back
for example to the nation of Israel and
ask people well are you from the tribe
of dam Manasseh they don't exist the
tribes so intermarried and and why would
you say exactly 12,000 from every tribe
remember we talked to about numbers in
the Bible being so significant three the
number of the godhead uh the number uh
of four the four corners of the Earth
the number seven Perfection six is
imperfection in the Bible um where seven
represents the truth six represents the
counterfeit triple six represents the
triple counterfeit that's contrary to
the will of God and the plans and
purposes of God what about 12 you have
12 tribes in the Old Testament that
represent the totality or universality
all of the the people of God you have 12
disciples that represent all the people
of God you have in the New Testament the
entire Church of God you have 12 gates
in the New Jerusalem representing all
Humanity that will come in you have 12 *
12 144 representing the total number of
saved at the time of the end wouldn't it
be rather strange to think that of the
78 billion people in the face of planet
Earth only 144,000 are going to be
redeemed at end time certainly God's
grace abounds in is much greater than
sin certainly God is going to have a
multitude that nobody could number that
Ascend to meet him in the sky of every
nation Kindred tongue and people 12,000
from every tribe tribe those tribes
don't exist today what's it talking
about that people from every realm of
this part of this globe every realm of
Life are going to come now how can we
identify this 144,000 even more clearly
remember we talked about the fact that
in Revelation chapter 7 and 14 we have
the
144,000 now there are seven
characteristics of the 144,000 we want
to take a look at here in Revelation 14
I looked in low and I stood on Mount
Zion with him 144,000 first there with
Christ on the on Mount Zion Mount
Zion was the mount that used to be a
jebusite fortress it was where David
establishes Citadel a little bit
southeast of Jerusalem it was a place of
safety the 144,000 ultimately will stand
with Jesus on Mount Zion they will be
secure from the chaos the Calamity the
heartache of the Earth but notice the
father's name is written in their
foreheads in the Bible the father's name
is his character now notice where the
father's name is written in their
forehead is there anything else written
in the forehead of somebody throughout
the uh Book of Revelation in Revelation
13 the mark of the beast is in the
forehead or in the hand what does the
hand represent it represents coercion
force or pressure we don't receive God's
name or his seal in our hands why not
because God gives us freedom of choice
he never coerces he never pressures us
but the beast power that arise at the
last days of verse history will have an
economic boycott pass that nobody could
buy or sell he will oppress God's people
he'll persecute God's people put God's
people in prison and there'll be a death
decree according to Revelation 13 that
hangs over their heads God's people will
go through why because they're sealed
the evil one during the time of trouble
the time of the seven last plagues
cannot touch them but they'll reveal to
a waiting world and a in a watching
Universe God's glory and his goodness
just like Shadrach Meshach and ab bendo
with into the fiery Flames but Jesus was
there with him Jesus will be with his
people I love that old song Just when I
need him Jesus is near just when I
falter just when I fear just when I need
him most Jesus will be with his people
then so notice these things about the
144,000 they have the father's name in
their foreheads the father's name they
are totally loyal to Christ they reveal
the father's character see the devil
puts his Mark in the for in the hand he
that convinces you with his lies John
8:44 Satan is the liar and he's the
father of Lies so he that deceives you
with his lies and gets you in your head
or he forces you and puts your pressure
on you to confir conform to his ways
even you don't believe it but Jesus
appeals to us with love he is the Lamb
of God who died for the sins of the
world and he appeals through his love
through his grace through his mercy of
what he's done for us to get us to come
to him so we notice these
characteristics second I Heard a Voice
verse two Revelation 14 as the voice of
many Harpers a voice of great Thunder
voice of harps with their Harpers they
sung as it were a new song Before the
Throne this the 144,000 sing a new song
what is that new song it is the song of
redemption it's the song of their
experience they have found Jesus
faithful in the most difficult time of
life they found Jesus faithful during
the plagues they found Jesus faithful
during the time of tribulation they
never gave up on Jesus but Jesus never
gave up on them they sing the song of
Victory they sing the song of Glory it
says nobody could learn that song but
the 144,000 who are these 144,000 the
144,000 is a term to describe those who
reveal God's glory who reveal God's
grace in the last days of ver history
they are spiritual Israelites that is
they are the Church of God the remnant
of God the people of God from every
nation Kindred tongue and people who
stand for Christ during the last days of
Earth history and do not yield their
faith we saw first that they have the
father's name in their forehead we saw
second that they sing a new song we saw
as well that these were not defiled with
women now notice what does it mean
they're not defiled with women in the
Book of Revelation you have two great
wom you have the true church the bride
of Christ adorned in white resined with
God's glory in Revelation 12 you have
the false Church the Scarlet woman in
Revelation 17 the true church feasts on
the word of God in Revelation 12 the
false Church in Revelation 17 passes
around the wine cup of her Doctrine
people drink of that and they become
intoxicated with that false wine of her
Doctrine these people have not defiled
themselves with false Doctrine they've
not been deceived by the spirits of
spiritualism and have accepted the
immortal Soul they've not accepted son
worship that has come down through Pagan
worship down through the centuries they
have been loyal to Jesus and loyal to
Christ so what do we know about them so
far they have the father's name in their
forehead his character is revealed in
their life they sing a new song they
sing the song of victory that Christ has
been with them they are not defiled with
women they have not accepted false
doctrines they are virgins that is to
say that they are pure and true and
chased to their one lover Christ
committed to him they follow the lamb
whereever he goes we follow him in
heaven because we followed him on Earth
we follow him there because we followed
him
here are you following Jesus here is
there anything in your life that would
keep you from living with him in
eternity the Holy Spirit now wants to
work in your life he wants to seal you
he wants to lead you into a place both
intellectually and spiritually so you
will not be moved in the final crisis
are you letting the Holy Spirit mold
your life are you letting the Holy
Spirit work in your heart are you
letting the Holy Spirit convict you of
sin and bringing things up deep within
the heart that you never knew were there
jealousy Pride anger bitterness are you
allowing the spirit to root these things
out of your life and shape you to write
God's law in your heart so you love
obedience to write God's law in your
mind so you know what he wants you to do
these are the characteristics of the
144,000 the Bible says as well thesee
follow the land wherever he goes they
were redeemed from among men in other
words these people came from Earth so
who are the
144,000 they are the final generation to
live upon the Earth
having the character of God in their
foreheads that character of God in their
minds they stand before God redeemed and
they sing the song of Victory they are
part of God's honor Convoy and they
follow the lamb wherever he goes they
travel with him from star to star planet
to planet they reveal his grace and his
goodness before unfallen worlds they are
redeemed from the the Earth they have
not accepted false Doctrine notice it
says they are the first fruits unto God
in the lamb what is it mean that they
are the first fruits of God in the lamb
for the first time in the history of the
universe an entire body of people or are
taken up to heaven without seeing death
remember what Jesus said through the
Apostle Paul in 1 Thessalonians 416 and
17 the Lord himself shall descend from
heaven with a shout with the voice of
the Archangel and the Trump of God the
dead in Christ shall rise first then we
which are alive we which are what alive
shall be caught up together with them to
meet the Lord in the air but here is a
generation an entire corporate body of
people Elijah Elijah was taken to heaven
without seeing death he ascended and was
translated Enoch was taken to heaven
without seeing death so we do have Enoch
and Elijah as examples in the old test
we don't ever have a corporate whole a
body of people that's who these 144,000
are they've lived through the time of
trouble the Seal of God's been in their
foreheads they cannot be moved they've
been Anchored In Christ through the
ministry of the Holy Spirit and the
Bible says here in Revelation chapter 14
that um it says they're the first fruits
of God in the lamb they are raised from
the dead the first fruits not in the
sense of time but in the sense of the of
the best that God has as a generation as
a church and he raises them from the
dead I mean he he they res they're
resurrected and they join those who've
resurrected from the dead and they
ascend with heaven with Christ it says
in their mouth was found no gu what does
it mean no guile in their mouth no
hypocrisy they don't live a double
life the grace of Christ transforms them
and they
stand before the universe and those that
are totally committed to Christ and then
it
says for they are without fault Before
the Throne of God why are they without
fault Before the Throne of God what
makes them without fault they have come
to
Jesus Jesus is their all and all they've
Found Jesus and that's all they want and
that's all they
need as Christ fills their heart
their
minds do not go wandering after other
gods their hearts are not
divided God is longing for a people with
an undivided
heart and you say Pastor Mark I don't
know how I ever could stand through that
time I feel so weak at times I don't
reflect his character how can I ever be
ready when he comes the Bible says
in Hebrews 12 ver1 and 2 it says he's
the author and finisher of our faith in
Philippians 1 Paul says that he had that
has begun a good work in you will finish
it if you allow
Jesus to come into your life today if
you tell Jesus I don't want to do
anything that you don't want me to do
Lord all I want to do is what you want
me to do but you said Pastor Mark I'm
not quite sure what he wants me to do do
the thing he puts in your heart do what
you believe will please him do you
remember what it says in John 8 ver 29 I
do always those things that please the
father get down on your knees play fair
with God be honest with God and say God
whatever pleases you I want to do who
are the
144,000 they are the redeemed who are
alive when Jesus comes their members of
what the Bible calls The Remnant those
who remain faithful and loyal to God
they are totally absolutely committed to
God and through his holy spirit God
seals them so they cannot be moved when
the crisis around them breaks would you
like to say Jesus I want to stand with
that group let's pray Father in
Heaven thank you so much for Jesus thank
you that we can live for you thank you
that we can be your children Lord often
in ourselves in our own lives we see so
much weakness but there is strength in
you seal Us by your spirit help us have
undivided hearts and help us stand for
you amid the crisis of the
world may the only thing we want is to
please Jesus now and through all
eternity in Christ's name amen